here we go
live once again
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
Riverview Griffin
I'll tell you why there was a delay in a
second but today is a big review episode
[Music]
um I saw the flash so I want to talk
about that where's the DC Universe going
what did I think of the flash
Idol on Max like wow I mean and some
other fun news and notes around the
internet but as usual
welcome back
[Music]
videos
all right y'all
okay so welcome back to riffing with
Griffin thanks for being here as always
I appreciate you uh
uh um what wait what's the what's the
thing here that we do oh yeah that's
right so hit the Subscribe button uh so
you get the notifications so you know
when I'm going live on Wednesday I had
to do this other thing today when I
would have normally done the podcast but
you know it was supposed to be early
then they hit me at last minute hey can
you come at 11 30 so I went at 11 30
instead of like the time that I was
supposed to go so anyways so that was
fun a movie thing so it's a Rotten
Tomatoes movie podcast uh so check that
out you know but anyways subscribe uh
you know I'm on Twitch daily so you know
check me out on there and patreon
content and then I I now know what I'm
gonna be doing for my patreon content
so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna just keep doing reviews and
stuff but like you know people are
always hitting me up about spoilers
always like Griffin stop spoiling stuff
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna do
more extensive spoiler recap reviews on
my River mcgriffin patreon Eric Griffin
patreon so if you're interested in that
and you really want to see me go in
depth on stuff that's where you check
that out but as usual thank you for
being here I appreciate you as always
for being a loyal referend with Griffin
um subscriber follower all that so I
appreciate it
um thanks for being because the first
one I want to do is I'm going to go in
depth into Black Mirror each episode
which is going to be like I say spoilers
so uh you know we'll do that what's
going on right now so you know
Rachel and her mom are downstairs
you know I say I'm about to start my
podcast you know
they're like okay that's it right so I
set it up put the thing to go live and I
said you know then I have to hit the
live button so I went out again I was
like hey
I'm about to go live I'm doing my
podcast okay I sit down to I'm about to
hit the button and then I get oh wow we
need to print something
I'm like what I'm live you know what I
mean about to go live you know and then
the printer doesn't even work this is
whatever is supposed to print they don't
go to the printer and my door to my
office creeps open
it is her mom
at the printer
just
you know I don't know man
you know what I mean like it's just
crazy
so you know I don't know it's just you
know when you're trying to do something
and then it's you know what it really is
it's like everybody's thing that they're
doing is the most important thing in the
world to them and no one else's thing
means anything or matters that's just a
human reaction that's like a natural
human thing you know you're like hey I
gotta do this you know it's like but
what am I like I heard there's an old
old saying lack of preparation by you
doesn't constitute an emergency for me
so think about that one you know
but anyways we're here it's riffing with
Griffin
um I did have a special announcement I I
did tease it last week but I have to
actually wait another week another week
you know all I'll say is this for my
special announcement that you're really
not supposed to announce these things
you usually should wait 12 weeks to make
these announcements so I'll just say
that
but it's looking good
so now announcement's coming
um
so uh what else let's see uh what dude
what else when I was in
I was in Nashville so I just did I just
did Nashville and Huntsville so shout
out to those two clubs had a really
great time at those clubs and so thank
you for the Nashville and the Huntsville
for coming out and then this week I'm
going to be in Arlington Texas in the
Dallas area at the Arlington improv so
you go to Eric Griffin Eric griffin.com
to get tickets
come check me out at the Arlington
improv I know it's like one of these
weird weekends because it's like July
4th you know so I don't know maybe
people already went out of town I don't
know what the show's gonna be like but I
always put on a great show that's uh
what I do uh I'm really funny I I love
doing stand-up it's my passion and I
love making people laugh so you get to
come out and check that out and so here
we are on the podcast riffin with
Griffin so you know and for the people
that have been here before you get it
you know what I do on this podcast you
know it's all kinds of stuff sometimes I
review movies you know if you haven't
been here before and you're like I
thought this was a comedy plug yes it's
like sometimes it is sometimes it's not
it is what it is so come and check me
out
yeah I'm spoiling the news it's because
it's like
because it's like you know what I mean
it is what it is you know we I'll we'll
officially talk about it but you know
but
Miss uh thing she she was like I want to
do it you know
so anyways
um here we are
so if you're in Texas area come on check
me out Arlington improv it is what it is
um what's going on oh you know what I'm
just going to get right into some news
and notes to oh no no first we're going
to do I forgot we're going to do
comments first let's get right to the
comments you know so I had a lot of like
I had some good comments and some rude
comments like you know like last week I
was talking about you know how Rachel uh
she's like a visual merchandiser at uh
one of the at a Target store you know
it's actually a great position you know
I mean but of course you got to hate her
still somebody said where's Rachel
working her Target shift
I wish no
um let's see
uh K Noah this is the comment section of
YouTube K Noah 55 love the episode
griflock Henry was my favorite episode
as well as uh BM
amazing day was my least favorite really
I liked amazing day one that was one of
my that's my second favorite but all
right so
he said by the way my username is my
name
well you got a weird ass name dude
uh
uh let's see what else we got here
oh somebody said oh this is from an old
episode uh uh when I when I was wearing
where are my like sort of bowler hats
but it was like yikes ditch that had
Griff
Rick 3PO
um let's see King K casing production
Eric looked like he ate Mario and Luigi
oh well that's rude you know that was
somebody trying to be funny it wasn't
very funny
um we had the target shift one
somebody wax pack weekend said Eric has
her working at Target is that legal
you guys are haters well these Target
haters man Target's actually a really
great company they got great Insurance
you guys are haters let's see what else
we got of course oh here's another
here's one of our weekly Matt Rife
episode uh
you know comments
hey Eric this video who's this Luke
Kendrick hey Eric this video was
suggested to me and I was wondering if
you think you could please hook me up
with a dinner and movie night with Matt
Audible and I think once a fake account
of his like some of my photos so that's
a sign in my opinion yours too right
Luke hilarious thank you for that
comment
let's see
um somebody said e money you need a new
podcast logo you know when you say
things like that that's not helpful so
why don't you send me a new podcast logo
how about that
instead of just you know criticizing so
you criticize somebody's clothes your
clothes suck okay well what clothes
would be good it's all on how you
approach things you know
hey I I think that if you had a logo
that was looked like this it'd probably
be probably do even better you know I
mean it's a just positive affirmations
way to talk but you know y'all [__]
on the internet so you know keyboard
Warrior system the only thing you know
how to do is be negative
um let's see official chesh Shire I
think I'm saying that right I don't know
as long as corporations are cheap AI
Will Survive and Thrive until eventually
there's only owners making money because
they've replaced their whole company
with AI including the AI companies
right you know you can have your own
name I don't know though
um I don't know about the AI these days
you know like the AI is
um
it's it's it's like it's actually it's
not really artificial intelligence like
it's just grab there's so much stuff on
the internet that is just kind of
grabbing and sort of figuring things out
but it's doing a lot of plagiarism so
it's like it's hard to really know if
this is like in our minds we think AI
we're thinking of like Tony Stark's
computer and it's like coming up with
stuff but a lot of the things that
people are using it for it's just
grabbing from other things on the
internet and putting it together it's
like the closest thing to like
fabricated uh you know
intelligence
but
I don't know so there's a lot of issues
about it you know of course the rider
strike and the actors are fighting about
using AI
but I was thinking about this if I was
one of these production not like Studios
I would say to the writers and actors
like this like the writers I'd be like
okay we won't use AI but neither can you
because
it's gonna be a tool that people are
gonna be using I hear people talking
about it all the time like hey outline
this for me and the AI outlines the form
hey make a synopsis for me so they're
using it like writers are going to be
using it to make their job easier but
they're going to be like hey Studios you
can't use it though it's like I don't
know if that's I don't know if that's
gonna work
um let's see what else we got here uh
let me see um a couple more comments oh
see here's somebody that was in
Nashville
Eric you killed it in Nashville at
Zanies well thank you
uh Stephen Beck 1665 love your rankings
of Black Mirror on these last episodes I
loved block Henry real great review
without ruining anything love you Griff
I mean yeah I tried not to ruin it you
know so you know it is what it is you
just gotta like you know stay with me
y'all stay with me all right anyways
that's the comments if you want to be a
part of the comment section of the
podcast just leave it leave a comment
and I if it's funny you know if it's
like even if it's hateful and if it's
written a certain way I still might read
it so
thank you for being here I'm looking at
and all the people that are listening
just on audio you know I do it live on
Wednesdays but thank you for supporting
me too on Apple music and all the
different places Apple podcast uh you
know Google all the different Amazon all
the different places you can listen
thank you for listening there too I
appreciate that so
thanks for everybody for being here and
all the people that are live in chat
right now
um thank you for being here too foreign
let's see so what was going on all right
so here's some like weird stories that
are going on in the world
um that I thought would be interesting
to talk about first one up is people can
now bet on the Special Olympics
so that's it with that
like what you bet know the Special
Olympics
I just
I don't know I just I don't know how
this how I feel about this
it's like
oh man
I hate to say this but is there going to
be handicapping oh that's terrible
Griffin
you know what I mean like why don't you
are you
are you even gonna be able to say that
like
how you betting on the Special Olympics
I mean this is like why does everything
have to be like you know they say like
let's treat everybody the same everybody
should be on an equal playing field
we're not we're not we're not all the
same we're not some people are stronger
some people are smarter some people are
faster some people are bigger some
people are smaller like it's just it is
what it is so to we do you we're we're
there is double stand it's like even
when you think of like the basic of what
people like to talk about like the
difference between men and women is
there a double standard yeah there's a
double standard and there should be we
have different standards for different
things how we communicate we have
different standards and so I just don't
know if
betting on the Special Olympics is
something that we need in our life
then you're gonna be
people gonna be in the stands you know
and then they're gonna be running and
you're gonna be like come on Corky it's
like what do you think you know what I
mean you're gonna be
you you betting your rent money on the
Special Olympics and you're gonna be out
there like yelling and screaming at
these Special Olympics kids talking
about treating people normal you're
gonna be mad so you're gonna be walking
you're gonna be at the gate you know the
the the Special Olympics kid that you
know didn't run properly fast enough are
you gonna be mad at them now it's like I
just don't know if this is do we need
this
do we need this
you know I just don't know I don't I
don't know you know what I mean dude who
you telling somebody in this chat just
said over 71 000 subs and only 100
viewers who you telling man I that's
exactly how I feel I don't know where is
everybody
they just don't come live you know
they'll watch it later I mean the the
the the YouTube algorithm I mean if you
want to talk about like I don't know
what it is
it's like I don't think they let I don't
think they allow people to go viral
anymore I don't think I don't think
they're I don't think they're letting
like here you know 71 000 people said oh
you know what I I'm interested in you so
boom and then YouTube goes okay I know
these people are interested in you but
we're not going to tell them I'm like
hey I'm here well we're not gonna really
announce it we're not gonna get it to
them because you know so it's like you
have to pay for that it's we I don't
know I I don't know your guess is as
good as mine man but I've been building
this up for years now on four years so
people go yeah they suck but they don't
hit the notifications or they sub and
they just they don't they check in later
or I I don't I don't get how it works
either man I don't get how it works it's
like when you see somebody on Instagram
you know it's like you know go to like
uh
um so you like you go to somebody's
Instagram like
let's go to somebody's Instagram and
I'll just I'll show you exactly what I
mean so you go to like you know like
what's messy so messy has like the most
followers on Instagram I believe it is
you know I believe
um
yeah yeah he has the most followers he
has
496 million followers let's go to our
website look and look at this okay so he
has
476 million followers
you go to this let's just go to one of
his posts okay so this post
has 8.6 million likes
so I could say the same thing to him I
could be like hold on a second
476 million followers and only 8.6
million likes something's fishy that's
just how it works it's like you're not
you're not we're not allowed to like
interact with or inform
are actual followers hey what's up
if they allowed that this would be such
a different experience I think for
social media but at the same time I get
it the company is like Hey we're
providing a really great service we're
providing a service of a billion people
that you could somehow interact with so
hey you know you're gonna have to pay to
do that I mean you know so I mean I get
it the company's got to make money you
know look at that you know this one only
this one you know you know you look at
all this you go this guy has so many
followers like this one only has four
million likes so that's like what is
that four million out of four that's ten
percent one percent
yes like your notifications don't even
reach your whole audience it's such a
weird thing man but anyways
I don't know how I feel about betting on
the Special Olympics it makes me feel
weird and you would think on the surface
of it oh you bet in this because we're
not making everybody feel normal but
then like gambling and there's something
kind of seedy about that it could easily
go from just fun and innocent to like a
thing you know
yeah I don't know what do you guys think
about it put some comments on there
right now
um here's another one this is a
um another weird story here is that uh
somebody goes to a pink concert and
throws their Mom's ashes on stage at a
pink concert
what
I have so many thoughts about this
first of all
there's like pros and cons right okay so
let's say your mom is a huge pink fan
like a huge pink fan like you have the
Fondest Memories of your mom listening
to Pink going to Pink concerts it's like
this is the thing so I get it it feels
personal
it feels personal it feels like they had
some sort of memory but like I said just
because it happens to you doesn't mean
it's important for everybody else but
that's just the kind of society we live
in right now we think everyone thinks
the world revolves around them
so this could have been a kind of thing
where it's like but you know you
probably can't get it it's not like you
could just get a hold of pink it's not
like you could just like call Pink's
manager and be like hey
um my mom died I have her ashes look she
was a huge fan
um there's like a sweet story about you
know she overcame cancer because we went
to your concert whatever the story is
is there a way we can like pour her
ashes on the stage I get that you may
never be able to get to Pink So you
decide you know what I'm gonna do this
gorilla style I'm just coming in and I'm
just throwing the ashes on the stage and
then like that's just for you Mom you
know
she's doing it like it's a 40. this is
for you Mom
you the pink
yeah
I'm with you classy nasty what happened
to just throwing panties on stage people
are throwing cell phones at artists but
you're throwing your Mom's ashes is that
even sanitary is there some sort of
Health concern with that can you just
throw dead at you know ashes of a living
person I don't even know if you're
supposed to even do that at the beach
even that's a kind of weird thing you
know you're taking kids to the beach and
you're swimming in somebody's pouring
ashes into the water I mean it's like
you know but I get it it's a personal
thing but it's just like damn what's
that about you know
so
I thought this was weird you know and
it's like
um
like in the video it's like a video pink
can be seen kneeling down to pick up a
small package mid song
and it said and she goes is this your
mom she nervously questions someone in
the crowd I don't know how I feel about
this she said yeah
I mean but you know
I guess there is a moment like if I'm at
a calm a comedy show and somebody threw
a plastic bag of you know and you're
like what the hell is this and then on
on the and then it's labeled like my
Mom's ashes you'd be like wait what but
at the comedy show of course you know
you could turn that into like but it's
like you do you feel do you feel honored
do you feel like wow you wanted to honor
your mom this way it's just like there's
a time and place for stuff man and I
don't know can't be healthy right that
cannot be healthy so
that was just one of the weird stories
of the week that I saw where I was like
why would you do that
but then again it's like like I say you
know people have their own
important
things people think they're important
you know everybody thinks their life is
the most important thing in the world
and they're like hey look this means
that and you know and you know the
mentality the feeling of it too you can
just imagine the person in their mind
being like nah I'm doing it I'm doing it
I'm throwing these ashes at pink I'm
labeling it so she like he threw the he
must have thrown the ashes at her and
then landed and she saw it it must have
been like labeled and weird and it's
like hold on what so I don't know
maybe it all worked out I didn't read
the rest of the story to see like how it
turned out but that's just one of those
weird stories man you know
all right
before I go into I want to do my reviews
I want to talk about the Flash
and I'm also going to talk about this
show the idol
so this portion I'm I'm not gonna spoil
it but I might so I'm just saying
spoiler alert
right now moving forward especially for
this show
Idol on
Max
or HBO I don't even know what we're
calling it now are we calling it HBO
we're calling it Max
it stars
the weekend
which he doesn't even go by that which
is so weird his real name I don't even
know a bill something like he got a
weird ass name
Lily Rose Depp Johnny Depp's daughter
who is falling and Suzanne's son okay
all right
we got I I don't even know where to
begin
and the show is produced by Sam Levinson
who is the creator of euphoria so if you
know euphoria
this has the same
sort of tone
um
this is like I don't even know where to
begin
about how bad this show is
this show
is one of the worst pieces of crap I've
ever watched
because of like what they think they're
trying to do and what they actually did
what they actually put out is crazy
so the show from IMDb it says after a
nervous breakdown
derails Jocelyn's last tour she's
determined to claim her rifle status as
the greatest and sexiest pop star in
America her passions are reignited when
she meets Tedros a nightclub
uh impreciaro with a sorid past
will her romantic Awakening take her to
a glorious New Heights or the depths of
dark or the deepest darkest depths of
her soul
even that description I wouldn't want to
watch the show or make the show you know
like you someone's pitching you that
you'd be like what man
where do I even begin
by the way
they canceled it
mid-season
that's how terrible it is
they canceled it already
on this article HBO's new original
series Idol is wrapping up after its
fifth episode causing many viewers to
wonder why the show is ending so early
imma tell you why it's ending so early
this look first of all
let me let me be positive first okay
what's her name oh this is this is I
want to talk about this guy too that's
the Sam Levinson guy
uh
Lily Rose Depp she's she's
going to be a great actress okay
this was a misstep I think she's going
to look back on this show and see what
she did on this show and be like damn I
wish I didn't do that
but in their minds I get where they
thought it was going to go but like the
execution was terrible
first of all
it's like pornographic
because it's like
why is this [__] naked for no reason
even the opening sequence I get it you
know and it's like the show is like very
smart in some ways the performances of
like her Handler team played by a like a
bunch there's a bunch of great actors
and actresses in this show okay the
bunch of great people in the show uh you
know they're doing a great job
being like in her life you know what I
mean like her manager played by Hank
Azaria and like you know
when I don't want the uh I don't want
the the preview to start because it's
gonna you like did you get flagged for
this it's so weird that you get flagged
you know like some of these people are
like you know really great you know
um
actually let me get off this screen
so the show opens up you know
it opens up and you're like
you know she's getting photographed you
know and she's like got this like you
know weird look on her face and she's
very got this exotic features and she's
very beautiful you know and you hear the
photographer like you know give me you
know give give me sad you know and it's
kind of showing off what a great actress
she is because she's giving you all
these looks and then it's all about her
being naked and then and then the
handlers like
um the nudity coordinator you know on
this it's like a whole big contrived and
you kind of get in a sense of like you
know this is some spoiled Rich you know
A-list celebrity singer but then you're
finding out that she had some tragedy in
her life and this is sort of a comeback
and you're kind of like you're not sure
who's in charge or what's going on or
who she is and and there's like a pop
song that's like it's it's kind of good
but it's like not and she's dancing and
then there's an Asian girl that dances
better than her but it's her best friend
and then her assistant it's like it's
just like it's a mess it's a mess
the show is a mess
and then like it's like like I said it's
very pornographic to me and
unnecessarily pornographic
where you go like and that's this guy
Sam Levinson
so let me talk about him for a second
like this guy it's like just go make
adult films man like just go do that
go make what you believe is Artsy porno
I can't stand when you know you're
trying to disguise
like this sort of literate nudity and
as like
a tool to tell a real artsy story
none of the nudity in this movie in this
uh not 95 of it does not service the
story it just kind of like it's very
jarring like she's choking herself and
masturbating on screen
and you're kind of like this is how you
want to show that she's got issues
okay
I don't know
I don't know if it was necessary
it's so jarring and the story is so hard
to follow that all you can think about
is like oh well this is this is
pornographic
and so this guy this is what he does you
know like Euphoria is like that I don't
know if you guys watch it for you but
it's sort of like base it's like high
school
sexuality and you know it's like it's a
lot of sex and a lot of nudity in it and
sometimes you just kind of like is this
necessary
like just Sydney Sweeney's titties got
to be out again like just all the girls
have to dress this way does it have to
be like where it's like it's like a
character like the sex in Euphoria
becomes a character and here's my issue
with it too though
you know there's a way to do it
you know there's a way to do it where it
could still be sexy and and you can
still use it without it being sort of
nasty uh pornographic or you know if
that's like it seems to me that that's
the only tool this guy likes to use to
tell stories and if you took that out
there'd be no substance
I don't know if that's true or not but
it feels that way here's my problem with
Euphoria then we'll get back to Idol
if you're gonna have everybody in the
shows
like somehow involved in Sex and there's
nudity and all this stuff but your star
never does that
look I get it Zendaya probably was like
I'm never doing you're never gonna see
my titties I'm never gonna be naked it's
never gonna happen I have a problem with
that
when
everyone else on the show is doing that
because then you just then it's just out
of place
I'm not saying I want to see that I'm
just saying it doesn't seem
like she's from a different Universe in
this universe
she's a drug addict
she's playing a drug addict
who never
does anything
where she's naked or anything like that
you're like wait this don't make sense
what happens is it becomes very
noticeable
and then you're out of the movie you're
actually out of it because you're
thinking oh yeah you think not even the
character Rue you think oh Zendaya
doesn't ever she she probably don't want
to be naked when you can notice that it
takes you out of the thing Hey look
female empowerment for actresses yeah
you there should be a way to be sexy
without you being naked there's a way to
do it there's a way to film it I've seen
it it looks great there's ways to be
romantic and loving without having to be
like pornographic
okay but if you're fighting for that
fight for everybody
not just you
don't just be you're the Starlight I'm
never gonna be naked but then don't care
that everybody else gotta be naked I I
got an issue with that
so anyways
cut two down idle now it's all adults
and they're all it's just nudity for no
reason just nakedness and pornographic
stuff happening where I go well dude
is this the only thing you know how to
do is this the only way you know how to
tell a story because it sucks
you know what I mean
it sucks
yeah like it's like someone in the chat
the modest drug addict what anyways so
in this show it's just so much
it's just so much like when they had her
choking herself and masturbating I was
like okay this is where they're gonna go
with this
and like that's the that's the thing you
remember the most like that she's got
this weird thing like she had like a cup
of ice you know and she's like you know
using it and then and then later they
reveal she broke the the you know she
cut herself you know it's like what what
what's going on here I think there's a
lot of ways to show the trauma that this
girl is going through without it being
like this
but let me tell you the real issue with
the show
another major issue the weekend
I mean
bro
bad bad
I mean
he must have went to a weekend acting
class at the Learning Annex and then
started doing this show
I don't believe this dude
at all
and like
I like him
because he embodies an artist okay
and I appreciate his attempt at what he
was doing
you know he he he made an effort he just
ain't good at it it's okay
you know what I mean it'd be like if I'm
going to an NBA tryout
I'm saying and I fear like hustling but
they like okay you 51 you're not gonna
make the NBA
I mean
here's my thing with the weekend
very much an artist so he comes out as
the weekend and he like he has an album
and he's got the weird hair you know and
you're like
you like his music and you like this
like the whole combination of things
that he did and you're kind of
distracted by the hair
and this character of this person but
you're into the music next time he comes
out you know his he wants to cut his
hair and his people are like dude this
is who you are what are you doing and he
decides nah
I'm gonna do it this way and he like now
he's like like looking like and then you
start to go oh you're a regular ass dude
I mean that's the thing about it like
you see him and you go oh you're just
regular it's fine like you know he ain't
super cute he ain't Justin Timberlake or
nobody like that you know what I mean
yeah you know what I'm saying he you
know he's a really talented dude but now
you're like oh okay
it still is an image based business
there's image and there's art and they
go together so now he like kind of
diluted the image and it's just like oh
this guy okay cool all right and I don't
know if he ever was as popular but he's
got still got some hits he got some jams
people still Rock to the weekend and you
know and now he like is like I don't
even want to be the weekend anymore now
I'm a bell or whatever his name is
um
how do you say his name a bell something
or other Taipei or I don't know he's got
a weird ass you know kind of ethnic name
and you you realize now oh that's why
you call yourself the weekend it's like
you don't want people having to figure
out how to spell your name and say it
and all this stuff
um you know and it's like that's how you
um
uh
that that's you know what he what he did
now you know
so he he's like you know
like who are you now so now he's like I
also don't want I'm gonna be an actor
and I'm not gonna be the weekend I'm
gonna be this person my real name is
stuff and you go but dude you're not a
movie star
it's like
it's different
the weekend reminds me of Lady Gaga
okay now
I'm not knocking Lady Gaga when I say
this I love Lady Gaga I've actually seen
Lady Gaga in concert like three or four
times
I saw a little intimate concert in New
York at the closing of this really
iconic Little Theater and it was a
really intimate show I've seen her like
I think I've seen Lady Gaga four times
she puts on a great show
she is talented she can sing she's a
musician
but when she was coming out they must
they were like and it's like very
parallel to the movie she was in like
yeah you ain't you're not you got big
ass nose girl you're short no you're not
you ain't fine you know what I mean
it's like yes I don't know if you're
gonna be able to sell and she was like
no no so she created a Persona she
created Lady Gaga who wears meat dresses
who like wears weird makeup and clothing
and and she became a thing and she was
like now I'm going to show you how
talented I am and it is amazing what she
did and she became an icon
doing that but when you saw her in that
movie with Bradley Cooper you were like
oh that's just Stephanie from down the
street
and it's and when you see her just you
know
regular girl you're like oh wow you
really did it you turned that into
something
bigger than itself
the weekend doesn't appreciate what he
created and now he wants to be oh I know
I want you to like the regular and then
it's like well we don't we could go see
that at the post office bro
you know we you're you look like my
homeboy that I went to school with
it's like it's not that ain't special
I mean I get it you know what I mean
this is no knock I'm just saying
they put him in this he produced it too
and it's like
so somebody said Robert said she was hot
and A Star is Born listen I get it okay
I'm just saying
that when you see that person she's a
beautiful woman okay I'm just telling
you but there's like levels to
when somebody's a movie star somebody's
got that charismatic when you see them
you're like damn
she she you could get with her that's
what I'm saying like you know like it's
not that you know she ain't a 10. you
know she ain't like this chick Lily Rose
Depp or whoever you know it's just it's
it's like I would see how record
Executives and marketing people will be
like I don't know if how what are we
gonna do with her and she was just like
nah [__] y'all I'm gonna show you what
you're gonna do with me I'm gonna become
a superstar regardless of what you think
what I look like you guys know what I'm
saying man I'm not trying to knock her
at all I'm just saying this is just
reality of like you know it's the reason
I'm not a leading man you know what I
mean I'm cute as hell you know what I'm
saying
but if I'm in a show or whatever it is
like I'm the best friend I'm the boss
I'm the guy that lives next door you
know it's it's like I'm I'm gonna be
Bradley Cooper's friend you know what
I'm saying it's it is what it is you
know
so anyways
he's just bad in this too he's bad it's
just Idol is bad
it's bad bad so
I'm gonna watch all five ever I'm gonna
hate watch all five episodes but every
episode I watched I was like I can't
believe they're making this show like
where is this going I think this guy Sam
Livingston I think you know I think he's
misguided right now I think he needs to
stop with the sex I think he needs to
just like make something because he's
got an artistic flavor there's a there's
a there's a
there's like a
it's a presence you know I mean like a
like a producer who has a certain sound
he's got his own style and I and I wish
that it wasn't it I wish it wasn't just
solely associated with nudity and lyric
sort of like behavior and and images you
know
unnecessary you know what I mean all
right anyway that's my idol review it's
trash
okay so let's get to the big review that
I wanted to do and like I say this could
be
spoilers
wait where is is this it wait hold up
where's my
oh no that's not it oh here it is sorry
one man show here I have to find the
thing all right let's talk about
The Flash movie
okay
where is it I thought I had it on IMDb
hold on me pull up IMDb Flash IMDb there
we go guys
okay here we go TV series uh now here it
is the movie Flash 2023. so it's a flash
Stars Ezra Miller Michael Keaton and
Sasha Kaylee I think I'm saying her name
right and a bunch of other people Ben
Affleck's in it all these people you
know what I mean
um we got duped okay let me just let me
just let me just start there
um we got duped this is um
this was terrible okay this is terrible
terrible movie and you know they wanted
to put it out way before but then like
Ezra Miller got in trouble and you know
what I mean and it's like you know it's
like we this you can't get in trouble in
cancer culture time uh it's like you
know people it's like if somebody does
something wrong gets in trouble they're
a drug addict they you know alcoholic
and they do dumb [__] in public you know
the cancer culture police are like they
need to be removed from from society
basically they want Ezra Miller to kill
himself that's basically
what cancer culture is they want this
person to remove themselves from society
and to never be seen again
that's how extreme the cancer culture
Vibe is
so but they invested a lot of money in
this movie I mean a production budget
for this movie was you know way over 200
million dollars the special effects and
all this kind of stuff and it's like
supposed to be some sort of like tent
pole in the series you know so it comes
out so they don't so now they're dealing
with this Ezra Miller is nowhere to be
seen for press for this movie they got
everybody else doing press and then
behind the scenes James Gunn takes over
DC they change the name of DC Universe
to DC DC Studios you know they announced
DC Studios or whatever it is and he's
supposed to be the one that's going to
do it so in his process of doing this
he's like well we're gonna fire Superman
we're gonna fire Wonder Woman and we're
gonna start over but we're gonna still
keep some of the people from the old one
the whole thing is confusing and
nonsense okay either start over or keep
everybody but this like I don't want to
see Aquaman and it's a new Superman I
don't get out of here okay if it's gonna
be this flash then in this Batman then
keep everybody it don't make no sense
man you can't give us a new Darren on
beat let's like just like Bewitched you
you can't give us a new Darren and then
have us sitting here like well what's
going on who's that okay who's that so
that's what they're trying to do it's so
disjointed it's it's like this isn't the
new and then here's the thing that
pissing me off too James Gunn is going
to come out and be like oh this is the
greatest superhero movie ever
and there was part of me that believed
him there was a lot of hype about this
movie he started that hype he was like
yeah oh this the greatest superhero
movie ever I'm really proud of it and we
were like okay James Gunn and then now I
look back and I go of course he's gonna
say that
he's got to say that he's in charge of
the studio now and this is a movie
they're putting out so I feel duped
okay
spoiler time I'm gonna I'm I'm only
saying that because I might say a couple
things but I'm not gonna but it doesn't
even matter this movie's trash okay it's
bad bad somebody in a chat said this is
the idol of the DC Universe
hilarious okay
Ezra Miller he is of he's a funny actor
he's funny and charming and quirky is
too much he's like it's too much for a
whole movie
to be that character it's too much
it's kind of like
and I've used this analogy before it's
kind of like you listening to like a
biggie you listen to Jay-Z album and
then Jay-Z got one of his like little
rap Protege coming in doing like eight
nine bars and you're like oh that was
fire and then you hear that person's
album and you're like oh you you might
need to just be doing eight bars on
somebody's track and that's it
that's Ezra Miller the character of
Flash
it can't carry a whole movie or or just
this story just is like
you know like somebody said how do you
spoil trash I completely agree now I'll
say the first like 15 20 minutes of this
movie was like a great Justice League
movie like I wish it was just like this
is what the Justice League should have
been is this first part of the movie
great
I don't I don't want to say great
special effects great attempt at Great
special effects
so
um X-Men the X-Men future like those the
old ones with the not the ones that like
it was like going back in time X-Men you
know they're like when they first
started so that the the that special
effects they had of the guy moving
really fast they did it better that that
was that's how you're supposed to do it
and I know the flash is trying to copy
that and with like humor
um
it wasn't good
but there's like a great Batman Chase
like that special effects was pretty
good you kind of felt like oh it's gonna
be an action-packed really fun movie
you know look spoiler Wonder Woman shows
up which I don't understand why why is
this [__] in the movie if you already
like fired her if Gail because she's
Wonder Woman to me like who are you
gonna get to be Wonder Woman now you
know but she's in the movie so I'm like
maybe they didn't fire her back because
they easily could have just re redone
that whole scene it wasn't even like she
was doing anything spectacular it was
just like you know I was like okay I
wonder why they did they film this later
because they're gonna bring her back
it's just the whole thing was just trash
and then Ben Affleck is my favorite
Batman I like him as Batman I love his
thing
so then it's like then there's this
whole rescue scene where there's like
babies falling and he has to like rescue
them all and it's funny you know he's
being too quirky and funny through this
whole thing you know he's at the coffee
shop trying to get a a sandwich and then
the guy behind the counter of course is
being obnoxious and taking too long and
then the flash has to like you know he's
like I gotta go you know I'm late for my
it's like it's too it's like overacted
quirkiness and I've been there doing
comedy's hard y'all let me tell you as a
comedic actor myself it's hard you tend
to push too much you tend to like be
like I gotta be the funny but funny is
about reacting it's about being in a the
funniest things are when somebody's
doing something normal or like they're
doing something normal in a place that
that's not supposed to be and someone's
reacting to that that's comedy you know
so sometimes you think as a comedic
actor that you have to like I have to be
extra to be I have to be fun me instead
of being in a funny situation ah it's a
whole nuanced thing we'll talk about it
another time but that's what I feel like
was missed they missed the mark in this
movie
um
and so there's this big fun fight
sequence and it goes you know
so now
his mom dies that's how they become
superheroes in the DC Universe okay it's
just one of their parents has to die to
become a superhero in DC so the Flash's
mom dies you know bat we already know
the Batman Origin story we know how
Superman's parents died and then his
like adopted dad dies we already know
that so that in DC Universe that's how
you become a superhero okay
so
so now it's about like sort of Flash
has a moment where he can run super fast
backwards and he somehow has a time he
could time travel
here's my issue guys
help me suspend my disbelief okay I just
help me
suspend my disbelief
perfect example of that is the first
Iron Man
I believed
Robert Downey Jr as Tony Stark that he
was making this product and that it
could fly and do what it did because of
how they set it up
movie Science movie
physics and you go okay I can believe
this I'm on board
The Flash no I don't believe it just all
of a sudden he went from like he's
running real fast which we already know
because he's the freaking Flash and now
he's running back in time
like there's no explanation there's no
like it just kind of go well why didn't
he I feel like he would have figured
this out already before this time I
figured like you know what I'm saying so
it just was kind of like what is what is
this what like how is he doing this you
know and then you know he goes back in
time he tries to save his mom and now
it's all Multiverse stuff so he goes
back in time just you know to fix it and
then of course that's why
um what's his name Michael Keaton's
Batman is there and it's like and then
you just kind of go I don't then you
either you either like
that universe or you don't and there's a
lot of like cameos throughout the movie
there's a lot of like you know Henry
cavizel is nowhere to be found which
it's like okay they got rid of him fine
and then it's like all the science in
the movie all the science I didn't
believe like how he becomes the Flash
and how you know and then there's a lot
of like he's interacting with himself so
it's like you know it's it's uh the the
the the the the clumps you know what I'm
saying now he's an index special effects
trash special effects
you're like wow you spent this much
money on this movie and this is how it
looks the babies looks terrible when
he's like clearly acting with another
CGI thing you're like that that sucks so
we're sitting in this movie like well
this sucks like no everything about it
was sucky
there's some funny cameos that you have
to be like really into the DC movie
Universe to really be like oh wow that's
cool that they did that and it still
looked like it still looked terrible I
mean just how the movie resolves itself
the whole middle part of the movie was
so boring so uninteresting and so then
when I left the movie I was like oh this
is why nobody's watching this movie let
me tell you there's a there's a
narrative that the movie didn't do well
because Ezra Miller's troubles nah man
it didn't do well because it's not a
good movie
that's it okay
so idle and Flash get one woo
whoa that's it that's all they get so
anyways y'all
on riffing with Griffin on my patreon
I'm gonna go into an in-depth recap and
spoiler of
Black Mirror go I'm gonna go Episode by
episode and just really delve into
because I really want to talk about some
of the things in those episodes that I
haven't spoiled if you've seen it you
already know
um so you know check check that out
check you know if you want to be a part
of my thing because I'm just trying to
like build up my riffing with Griffin
like that guy said earlier it's fishy
how is there 70 000 review uh
subscribers but you know not not a lot
of people that you know I get maybe five
or six thousand views and I'm gonna also
try to get some more guests on and try
to do two two episodes you know so I
have my guest and I have my what I do
like this
you know maybe a couple patreon ones in
in in instead while I have a guest or
something like that you know I'm trying
guys I love doing this that's why I keep
doing it uh you know I don't I don't
necessarily want to stop doing it so you
know I appreciate you guys being here as
always
um
you know here on riffen with Griffin you
know we do what we do you know so make
sure you
subscribe you know so that's how you can
help me out you know you got to hit the
Subscribe button so you can know when
I'm going live hit the notifications for
me please I'm on Twitch I'll be on
Twitch in a little while I'm probably
gonna grab some lunch first
and I'll be on Twitch and like I said
man I am uh I'm gonna do patreon oh and
here's how I'm gonna do my patreon too
it's gonna be connected with my twitch
so I'm gonna do it live on Twitch
subscriber only so when you go to the
twitch if you're not a subscriber you're
only going to be able to watch for like
a few minutes and then you have to be a
subscriber to continue so if you're a
twitch subscriber you're gonna get that
and then I'm gonna upload that to
patreon for my patreon people so you can
either be a twitch member or a patreon
member and and I'm also going to upload
it to YouTube for my YouTube members
only and so I have a few YouTube members
right there so
and I'm going to change the pricing on
that it's going to be all the same price
on all three on all three things so I
appreciate you guys uh for your support
you know I I know the ones that support
you hit me up I appreciate the messages
and even you troll pieces of [__] I you
know I I appreciate the interaction
you're making an effort you know what I
mean like you're like you know you're
making an effort to be like I'm gonna
come say something out of pocket here
it's just so I can like get a rise you
know I mean I I react because that's
part of the the fun you know I mean I am
who I am I'm an emotional guy and I like
being like that but trust me nothing's
really honestly getting to me so for you
people who are like man you know you
don't believe that dude trust me I'm
fine
I got a great life going on and look out
in the coming weeks for a big time
announcement as I said I kind of already
spoiled it but you know it is what it is
but anyways y'all know what time it is
now
it's time for
brat
recap
Eric Griffin coming back
those haters get slapped
[Music]
I was watching idle
I don't know why
they try
that show was now in the sky
but I don't give up
geez who goes
throw ones your ashes on the stage at
peace
[Music]
you know
with these old man raps
[Music]
back see you next week